[Music]
this general dissolution of the shapes
of the essentiality as a whole in their
individuality becomes in its content
more petulant and bitter in so far as
the content has its more serious and
necessary meaning
the divine substance unites within
itself the meaning of natural and
ethical essentiality
as regards the natural element actual
self-consciousness shows in the very
fact of employing things of nature for
its adornment for its dwelling and also
in feasting on its sacrificial offering
that it is itself the fate to which the
secret is revealed that is the truth
about the essential independence of
nature
in the mystery of bread and wine it
appropriates this independence along
with the meaning of the inner essence
and in comedy it is conscious of the
irony of this meaning generally
now in so far as this meaning contains
ethical essentiality it is partly the
nation in its two aspects of the state
or deimos proper and the individuality
of the family partly however it is a
self-conscious pure knowing or the
rational thinking of the universal
this deimos the general mass which knows
itself as lord and ruler and is also
aware of being the intelligence and
insight which demand respect is
constrained and befooled through the
particularity of its actual existence
and exhibits the ludicrous contrast
between its own opinion of itself and
its immediate existence between its
necessity and contingency its
universality and its commonness
if the principle of its individuality
separated from the universal
makes itself conspicuous in the proper
shape of an actual existence and openly
usurps and administers the commonwealth
to which it is a secret detriment then
there is exposed
more immediately the contrast between
the universal as a theory and that with
which practice is concerned there is
exposed the complete emancipation of the
purposes of the immediate individuality
from the universal order and the
contempt of such an individuality for
that order
745 continues hegel's all too short
exposition
and examination of comedy
as a genre and we should remind
ourselves that he's not attempting to
provide a general theory
of comedy here
it's situating comedy as you might say
the end of the really essential
aspects of both epic and tragedy so
comedy is
not just a
genre of drama
and a way of relating oneself thereby
perhaps to the gods you know as was done
in the festivals of dionysus
it's actually a dissolution of the
religious
relation we could say within
ancient greece comedy is an acid
that corrodes and it doesn't just
corrode by you know poking fun at the
powerful or something like that
it's
showing how things are we saw in the
previous paragraph the actor takes off
his mask plays with the mask because he
wants to
show forth something
you know something true something right
something genuine at vas rectus right
now we're getting to see
what happens not just to the gods
but to other important
powers
you could say and you notice that hegel
you know the second part of the
paragraph
is concerned with the
two sides of what in spirit were the
ethical substance the
state you know the we've talked about
this before the law
of the state or translated here
commonwealth and then the the law of the
family right these these two powers
and the state is going to be revealed as
in a certain respect not living up to
its own self why because it has to take
on
actuality actuality
can you know be
very
what should we say actuality is the test
for hegel of what an idea what a notion
what a norm really is what happens when
you put it into actuality what happens
when you strip
the mask off
of theory and you go to the realm of
practice
opposition he's going to talk about in
here but there's more than that going on
there's a really interesting parallel
that's taking place and there's this
observation that hegel
is making at the very start that we we
really need to dwell on a bit
so he says
this general dissolution of the shapes
of the essentiality as a whole in their
individuality becomes in its content
more petulant and bitter
in so far as the content has its more
serious and necessary
meaning okay so there there's a lot
going on there just in that little short
sentence
the general dissolution oligon of losing
the
you know the falling apart the analysis
the uh corrosion that is happening to to
what to we in the last paragraph the
shapes the forms were
the gods right which were revealed to be
mere representations just in imagination
something that we've come to realize in
previous paragraphs shapes of the
essentiality
gestaltene vasenheit formed
essentialities right and notice that
hegel talks about their individuality
right so each of the gods is supposed to
be an individual we've discovered that
they really aren't
we're already prefiguring what we're
going to find out a little bit later and
something that foyer bach by the way
will take from hegel and really run with
that these are we saw this already in
the unhappy consciousness though these
are just projections
of
self-consciousness of a part of itself
out there into
imaginary land the whatever we want to
call it of the eternal the pure the good
what it is that
matters these representations are not
real things i mean they could be
allegories for real forces the way that
the stoics
made them uh but we're not there yet and
then he's got this this interesting
point right
the content
let's read this one more time
becomes in its content so not in its
form in its content what could its
content be
language
you know comedy tragedy epic these are
all forms of language we saw that this
entire section
is about the
um
language that goes beyond the other
forms of religious language that we saw
culminating in the cult like the oracle
or the hymn right
and instead now we have
um
you know dramatic
and and uh imaginary
uses of language and
the content the more serious
right the more um
you know seemingly
authentic uh concerned with important
things and necessary not vendika right
the more necessary it's meaning it's
what it's what it's referring to
the more bitter
bitter right and petulant
the more the more angry the more
resentful right the word there that i'm
blanking on it has moot in it right the
mindset or feeling
in any case
the
whatever we're going to call it
the people who think that the gods
matter the people who think that the
divine liturgies matter that all of
these
former
accorded almost like absolute belief
they become
irritable they become
bitter is a great word for it you know
they they
they don't have any real power left
except in language to condemn to
complain
and
is it the gods doing this no the gods
we've already understood the gods don't
actually do anything
it's people doing it right okay so this
is a very important
set of points right
then he talks about the divine substance
the divine substance is not the gods
we're finding out right the divine
substance the ethical substance that we
saw so centrally in spirit and also in
the reason section the uh essentiality
that we're trying to grasp in the
unhappy consciousness
the divine substance unites within
itself he says the meaning
of natural and ethical essentiality so
that means that there's there's uh two
sides
to this in this divine substance which
is part of what we're looking at in the
religion section
natural essentiality
and
ethical essentiality here we have this
really important contrast
that we see between the realm of
culture that of human beings and that of
nature but even nature itself
is not going to be
solely or purely
natural it's already a nature
for
human beings as as we see
how do we know this well let's take a
look at the first side the natural side
says as regards the natural element
actual self-consciousness via clicker
voice side actual you know real
self-consciousness
shows
in the very fact of employing
using making use of
right things of nature now the the
the things of nature that's
uh not there in the german
uh it's their celibate right um
so making use of the things that belong
to it of nature but it could also be
read as making use of those things that
fall within its own scope the scope of
actual self-consciousness that exists in
a natural world and this is very
interesting
you know
we've got all these great dialectics of
self-consciousness you know you remember
this from the self-consciousness section
because it's the most famous thing the
struggle to the death self-consciousness
is desire self-consciousness cannot
exist without another self-consciousness
to which it relates itself we're
struggling for recognition all that is
true right that's all there
but here hegel is being brutally
realistic self-consciousness
doesn't just exist in relation to
another self-consciousness they both
exist in relation to a natural world
which even if we live in the midst of a
metropolis
we are still part of insofar as it rains
upon us or we use products that were
generated ultimately using raw materials
the very fact that we eat
and we consume that we wear
all these things you know even if we say
oh well you know if you live in a purely
plastic environment right plastic comes
from petroleum or from corn or whatever
else you're going to make it from
sooner or later
we human beings exist in relation
to the natural world and not just as
consciousness to nature
but as
self-consciousness to nature so we exist
as self-consciousness in relation to
other self-consciousnesses
we exist as self-consciousness in in
relation to those gods that we project
we exist as self-consciousness in
relation to
the environment the things of nature
and he gives us some examples of this
this is not an exhaustive list of course
right
employing things of nature for
its adornment
putting things on i mean it could be as
simple as like you know um finding a
coconut shell to cover up your your junk
right
and it could be anything you know up to
the very elaborate uh silk
robes you know with many many things
embroidered on them anything in between
too dying is taking things from the
environment and using them for their
pigment we could go on and on and on
with analyses of this what else
dwelling
having a place to actually stay this is
something i mean you know think about uh
anthropology and archaeology how do we
know things about ancient humans
they stayed in places
they created shelters they created
tools that they used not just to
you know cut up their food or kill their
food or harvest their food
but to store their food to eat their
food out of and then they'd you know
break it up and leave the pot shards
around for us to discover many many
millennia later
um so dwelling is is an important aspect
and then feasting feasting on its
sacrificial offering the opfa right the
the
sacrifice itself
um
he says it actual self-consciousness
shows what
that
it is itself the fate the chick zal
discussed in the last paragraph the fate
now not of the gods but the fate of
nature
the fate to which the secret the
kindness is revealed
the truth about the essential
independence of nature now essential
independence
zelps vase and height
is that the best translation for this
i mean it kind of works zelfsveisenheit
its own
essence
due to itself right now think about what
how nature presents itself to us
i'm not talking about nature capital n
like the totality of everything think
about the is he's going to talk about
the grain and the wine right those are
determinate things they're also species
beings in the grapes and in the grain
itself that's going to be baked into
bread those are to some degree
these and heighten aren't they
um you know the whether we live or die
the grapes continue to exist
if you've ever you know wandered around
and come across wild grapes
uh which are you know not particularly
uh big and oftentimes quite sour because
they haven't been domesticated changed
by us human beings now that gets that
something right
the big grapes that we like to eat you
know and maybe peel or they have seeds
they don't have seeds
we have not just used them we have
modified them and that's holding even in
hegel's time and that's holding even in
the time of the ancient greeks because
our transformation
of grains and fruits and
animals as well
and the natural environment think about
digging irrigation ditches
is how we
convert nature to our
use right
so to what degree are natural things
actually
zupp's vase and height
subspace and heightened and to what
degree are they
instead dependent on the actual
self-consciousness of humanity
so he says you know for example in the
mystery of bread and wine it
appropriates this independence along
with the meaning of the inner essence
in comedy it is conscious of the irony
of this meaning generally so what is
hegel doing here he's saying we can look
at what's going on here and then we can
think about comedy
as a way of consuming
making use of transforming
all the things of our
culture
so now we turn to the side of the
ethical
essentiality right
he says insofar as this meaning the
meaning of divine substance
contains ethical essentiality
it is now hegel does his typical
breakdown i mean is this is this really
necessary to do the two sides of it i i
don't think so but you know hegel is
pretty fixated on this schema so let's
see where he goes with it we have the
side of the state
uh the stock right or the damos proper
the eigen naken deimos i eigen lincoln
yes proper
its own
deimos its own
ethical uh people right
and so he says we got that side and then
we have the individuality of the family
and he's not really going to talk about
the individuality individuality of the
family very much at this point we've
already you know
we've we've plumbed that a lot in in the
sp the spirit section
and earlier even in the religion section
we probably don't need to add anything
what's really interesting here though is
how what he calls the principle of
individuality
takes root what it does
in relation to the state
so
again not not totally original points
here
the state the side of the state whether
we identify it with you know the idea of
the state or the human law as opposed to
the divine law whatever we're going to
look at
there's a a fundamental problematic here
who is the state
aristotle actually raised this problem
in the politics when he said
who is the
regime
it's not the same thing as the
constitution you know the constitution
of athens would be
well it's a democracy and it has
this history and it has
um these particular ways of organizing
thing what does an archon you know a
ruler do
how are juries selected that's all the
sort of like you know background theory
stuff and then there's the well how who
is actually in charge here who's doing
things who got elected this year what
does the jury look like this time right
and that is the
government or the regime
and not mixing one up for the other
although we have a common tendency to do
that
is quite important isn't it
so he goes on and he says
this deimos
um the general mass which knows itself
as lord and ruler
and is also aware of being the
intelligence and insight which demand
respect
is constrained and befooled through the
particularity of its actual existence so
let's
focus in on that right so
we're talking about a deimos not just
you know a tyrant not just a
oligarchical or aristocratic ruling
class but really the the whole people
you know the ethical people he i think
he does have like something like athens
in mind here
and the deimos
they're not as smart as they think they
are
in a certain sense because they are
public rationality can have a greater
play among them aristotle recognized
this too a non-athenian
uh who was rather distrustful of
democracy he said well you know putting
together a bunch of people is likely to
if so long as they don't degenerate into
tyranny you know more opportunities for
discussion discussion of things and
putting forth
um you know your your best appeals
um it's sort of like you know uh it's
better than to have too many people
talking than than not enough people
talking so the deimos manages to
befool itself
through the particularity of its actual
existence
this could mean a lot of things this
could mean
you know focusing too much on the
situation that you're dealing with it
could mean using the deimos and its
political power to settle scores
but there's also something more
universal about this the very fact that
somebody is selected to speak for
and rule in in the place of the deimos
means that the deimos is not going to be
fully represented even when it thinks
that it is
and he says it exhibits the ludicrous
contrast between its own opinion of
itself
and its immediate existence
how often is this the case
for our contemporary governments
and our you know political uh
communities
where
we're fooled by the fact that oh yeah we
elected somebody or somebody's in charge
and we take them as as being like the
genuine representative and not just the
you know
least bad schmuck who happened to
blunder their way into being put in
charge of things
and we could say this so much not just
about uh political commonwealths we
could say this about educational
institutions we could say this about
corporations you know if you think that
the ceos are the best and the brightest
man you haven't spent enough time in in
corporations because very often they're
not you know it's not as if you know
intelligence and talent just somehow
gravitates upward there's often a lot of
uh
mischances we'll say with that so he
goes on and he says
it's you know the ludicrous contrast
between its own opinion of itself and
its immediate existence between what
its necessity and contingency
we talked about necessity a little bit
earlier didn't we
it's universality and commonness
and then he says if the principle of its
individuality
separated from it the universal makes
itself conspicuous
in the proper shape of an actual
existence and openly usurps and
administers the commonwealth to which it
is a secret detriment this is this is a
very common thing that happens right
somebody gets elected oh i'm going to be
a reform candidate we're going to
finally get things back on the right
track we're going to get closer to the
ideals and then they find out just how
difficult it is to rule and that you
know the treasury is kind of empty and
things aren't working the way that
they're supposed to and the rich are
getting away with a lot of stuff that
they're they're not supposed to and
they're like oh man all right let's
start cracking some heads and making
progress and suddenly everyone's like
wow why did we vote for this guy he's
not representing me you know he's a
detriment to the commonwealth
and so it goes on right he says if it if
it uh openly usurps it administers the
commonwealth to which it's a secret
detriment
then there is exposed more immediately
the contrast between the now i love this
the universal as a theory
and that with which
practice is concerned
if if that isn't hegel's
uh
one aspect of hegel's political ideas
in a nutshell and ethical and religious
you know there's theory on the one hand
and theory is really awesome you gotta
have theory
and then on the other hand there's
practice and practice is where
very kite reality
happens and your theory
actually gets put into practice and
tested and you find out that things
aren't quite so
straightforward and easy so he says
there is expose the complete
emancipation of the purposes
of the immediate individuality from the
universal order and the contempt of such
an individuality for that order there is
a kind of cynicism here
uh in in play on the part of the
governors they're like wow you know now
that i'm in i see how much more
complicated things are but these people
who elected me
they
don't know what the hell is going on so
i'm going to manage things
for their benefit but also for mine you
know
and uh you know i don't have to take
them that seriously because they're a
bunch of rum dums they don't actually
know what's going on
and you know we see this dynamic over
and over again
now
that's where the paragraph ends
you say what does this have to do with
comedy which is only mentioned
in the middle
well
in comedy
and it now let's think about this in two
ways in comedy
as a genre
we can find things like this and it
could be in the state it also could be
in the family and it could be in other
things people are given some sort of
scope to make decisions they screw them
up people criticize them you know we
laugh we we sometimes it's a bitter
sardonic laugh you know
sometimes it's a genuine laugh
we also have you know all this stuff
over here going on uh as being part of
the divine substance
comedy writ large so moving away just
from the genre this comedic
aspect that we are now exploring
is in fact a dissolution an auf losing
right and we're finding it's not just of
the essentialities that are the gods
it's also of the natural essentiality
when we come to realize nature is what
we are making of it of course there's
plenty of aspects that are resistant to
us hidden to us but it's not as if we
ever have a primal nature that you know
we're entering into
and it's totally untouched just by being
there as self-consciousness we're
already making it human and then we've
got this ethical essentiality that could
be explored in many other ways
it could be about all sorts of other
relations not just that of political or
familial
[Music]
but all of these are subject to this
this kind of
dissolution
that hegel is narrating here
you